NICK: To kick us off, the
first thing we're going to do
is actually watch a quick
video about the Kenny Aronoff
experience before
Kenny comes up here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- To have him performing
right in front of you, along
with being a
motivational speaker,
is such a unique combination.
It was absolutely remarkable.
- And I realized there
were seven things--
I narrowed it down to seven--
that have made me successful--
the same seven ways that I
have an extraordinary life
in the music business,
which is so unpredictable,
for over 3 and 1/2 decades.
- The life principles--
you don't get to his level
without the education
and the dedication
and the hard work.
- I motivate my audiences
from my experiences playing
with people like Sting, Elton
John, people like Buddy Guy,
Ray Charles, Avril
Lavigne, Michelle Branch.
Every experience I have, it
seems like a life-changing
experience--
made me grow, made me
become who I am today,
has helped me become successful.
We're going to play a bunch
of songs from some artists
that I've recorded
through the last 35 years.
I'm going to tell
you some stories.
And then I want to share with
you how I became successful
and have stayed successful
in the music business, which
is one of the most difficult
businesses in the world,
for 35 years.
And what I tell you will
transfer into anything
you do in life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
NICK: So Kenny has
drummed on over 60
Grammy-nominated or awarded
recordings, representing over
$300 million in
sales, with over 1,300
that went gold,
platinum, or diamond.
"Rolling Stone" cited him as
one of the top 100 drummers
of all time.
He's the author of "Sex, Drums,
Rock and Roll," Kenny Aronoff.
[APPLAUSE]
KENNY ARONOFF: Hey, Nick.
Thank you.
Awesome.
NICK: So Kenny, let's
start from the beginning.
How did a kid from
rural Massachusetts
become one of the most
famous drummers of all time?
KENNY ARONOFF: Well, I was just
a little kid playing outside,
because there was nothing
to watch on TV back in 1801.
Well-- and so there was
nothing to watch on--
we had a little black RCA
TV set with the rabbit ears.
And so there was
nothing to watch.
So we played outside.
And one day, my mom yelled at my
brother and me to come inside.
And I thought I was in trouble.
I came in like, uh-oh.
And the Beatles were on TV
at the "Ed Sullivan Show."
And I looked at that.
And naively, as an
11-year-old kid,
I just said, Mom, I want to be
in the Beatles, call them up.
And then I saw the drum set.
And Ringo's playing.
And I'm like, that is so cool.
And being a hyper kid, I
related to what Ringo was doing.
I said, Mom, I want a drum set.
Silence again.
And so she obviously
didn't call the Beatles up.
And so I started my own band.
When I'm passionate
about something,
"no" is not an option.
So I started my own band
called the Alley Cats.
I was gardening
at $0.50 an hour.
And I saved up enough money
for a snare drum and a cymbal
and started my own band
and played Beatles music.
And that's how I got started.
But the amazing thing
about that story,
in the light of dreams come
true, is 50 years later,
I'm playing with Paul and
Ringo on a CBS special--
a tribute to the Beatles
for that "Ed Sullivan Show."
So really, my story is,
how did a little kid who
saw the Beatles at 11
and 50 years later, I'm
playing with them.
You had to be relevant.
And you had to be happening
and still in the game.
I guess that's the end
of the interview, right?
We're done.
Any questions.
NICK: Now you didn't have
immediate success right away.
So talk me through the
time at Tanglewood.
I think you didn't get in
on your first three tries.
And it was the
fourth time that you
got into Tanglewood, which is
the Boston Symphony Orchestra.
KENNY ARONOFF: Well, my
education went like this.
When I was young,
rock and roll was new.
So there was no
mentors or a teacher
to teach me how to
play rock drums.
But the Boston Symphony
Orchestra was three miles away
from my house in Western Mass.
So I don't know.
Somebody told me about this
percussionist, Arthur Press,
who was in the Boston
Symphony Orchestra.
So I started studying with him.
And he maybe played tympani and
mallets and not rock and roll.
But I had nowhere to--
I wanted to become educated.
I wanted to learn more.
Taught me how to
read and theory--
and in my family, we
all went to college.
So when it came time to, what's
your major going to be, I went,
music.
That was like the most logical.
So I started to
apply to colleges.
And I got into the
University of Massachusetts.
And I was not in the high
school band, the marching band.
I had my own rock band.
I didn't want to
listen to squeaky
clarinets or
out-of-tune violins.
I was playing in clubs when I
was 13, playing Led Zeppelin.
Why would I want to do that?
But I was behind when it
was time to go to college.
And I got into UMass.
And the reason why I got in,
the teacher was blown away by--
part of the audition is
they put some music up
you've never played before.
And you're supposed
to sight read.
And I'd never even
played a marimba before.
And I'm trying to
play this marimba,
because I had a set of vibes
at home that I practiced on.
I'm trying to sight read.
I missed most the notes.
And the teacher
went, oh, um, well--
I went, no, I'm going
to try it again.
I think I stayed there
for five minutes,
trying to learn this piece
right in front of him.
And he went, I'm going to
enjoy teaching this guy,
because this guy works hard.
He's trying.
He really wants to make it.
So I got into UMass.
And then during that year, even
though I wasn't the greatest,
my eyes were always
forward-thinking.
I got to be with the best
school with the best musicians.
Up the road about five hours
was Eastman School of Music.
I applied there to transfer.
Got in, but there was no room
for me as a transfer student.
And there was this
hot cellist that
was a junior at UMass
who said something
about going to Aspen
School of Music,
run by Juilliard--
summer program.
I went, ooh, I got to go.
So I auditioned.
And the audition was play
three out of four categories,
like snare drum,
tympani, marimba,
and multiple percussion.
Well, I made a tape
of all four, thinking
I'd get some extra credit.
I don't get in.
Last day of school,
I'm going to go home,
study with the percussionist
from the Boston Symphony
Orchestra.
I got a rock band.
And as I was leaving school,
I went, oh, I forgot my--
I should check my mail.
I go there.
Looks like there's a check.
And I open it up.
And it's, you've been
accepted to Aspen.
Two weeks later, I'm in Aspen.
Worst percussionist
there-- by the way,
the cellist never showed up.
But I was the worst
percussionist there--
one of my most humiliating,
degrading experiences
in my life.
I got in, but I was the worst.
But if you look at the picture
that was taken of all of us,
I may have been the worst,
but I became the most famous
and probably the most
successful out of that group,
from just pounding it
in like a running back.
I've just been that running
back that just keeps--
all I see is the end zone.
And I have a line
that's like, I'll never
be as great as I
want to be, but I'm
willing to spend the
rest of my life trying
to be as great as I can be.
It's like a running back.
The greatest running back--
you name me the
greatest running back,
and he definitely doesn't
score a touchdown every time
he gets the ball, does he?
He doesn't.
But he's constantly,
play by play, game
by game, season by season,
looking at that end zone.
And that's how you
become successful.
So at that music
school was a teacher,
who taught at Indiana
University School of Music,
which was rated number one in
the country in classical music.
It was Indiana
University, Juilliard,
which ran Aspen, and Eastman,
which I had an audition for.
So I'm like a bottom
feeder at UMass,
but I was going for the top.
And I get into
Indiana University.
The teacher up there that
taught-- very, very demanding,
very strict audition.
That school is kind of like
being in the Navy SEALs.
They're going to weed you out.
If you get in, you have to
prove yourself constantly,
because that's how they
keep their standards high.
They always have
the best students.
And I saw many people
get washed out.
Anyway, I did four years there.
Back to Tanglewood--
so Tanglewood
had this very elite,
number one student
orchestra in the country.
So I auditioned in I
think my first year
at Indiana University.
Horrible audition--
I don't get in.
Second year, I'm better.
Third year, I don't get in.
It's like strike
three, you're out.
And I'm like, no.
Once again, I was passionate.
I got to get into this thing.
I got to.
I go back a fourth time.
I get in.
I work with Leonard Bernstein,
Aaron Copland, Arthur Fiedler,
[INAUDIBLE],, mentored by the
Boston Symphony Orchestra.
You are well-groomed.
And when I graduated
college, I'd
gotten to the Jerusalem Symphony
Orchestra and Quito, Ecuador
Symphony Orchestra.
And not to jump
ahead, but that was
the end of my formal education
pretty much, as far as
orchestral stuff.
NICK: Let's jump ahead,
because Bloomington
and being at Indiana
ultimately led
to you meeting John Mellencamp.
KENNY ARONOFF: Right.
So when I was at school,
I didn't meet John.
What I did was--
I talk about seven ways to
be successful in your life
and career.
And one of them is
to create a plan,
execute the plan to
reach your goals.
A lot of people have ideas, but
they don't know how to execute.
You have to take action.
Zero equals zero.
You do nothing, you get nothing.
So if you're waiting for
something to pop out of the sky
by just sitting on
your couch watching TV,
ain't going to happen.
It's not going to happen.
I made my career.
I made it happen.
And so when I got into the
Jerusalem Symphony Orchestra,
my passion to be
in the Beatles was
so strong I went back
to creating a new plan,
because I had executed
my first plan, which
I call the American dream.
You go to college.
You learn a trade.
And then when you
get out of college,
you get a job in the
field that you studied.
That's what my dad did.
That's what my mom did.
That's what this
country was built
on-- that type of thing and
hard work and self-discipline.
So my passion to
be in the Beatles
was so strong, what do I do?
I go back and live
at my parents' house,
humbly, in Western Mass and
start studying with a drum set
teacher in New York, a
drum set teacher in Boston,
practicing eight hours a
day, seven days a week.
And I should add that when
I graduated high school--
the day I graduated
high school, because I
was so afraid I was going to be
behind in the classical world,
I started practicing eight
hours a day, seven days a week,
relentlessly.
Everybody's partying
before they go to college.
Not me.
And not to get off track, but
I have a new book I'm writing.
And it's like the why would
I do such a thing like that?
What motivates me
to be what I am?
And I'll tell you what it is and
what it was back then-- fear.
Fear to fail.
Failure, to me, was like dying.
It's like, I refuse
to die on the vine.
That's my phrase.
I live my life loud.
I go after stuff.
Yeah, man, 4:00 in
the morning-- you
know that feeling when
you're like, oh, my god,
what am I doing?
Oh, this isn't working--
or you feel that
insecure feeling.
Well, you know at that
hour, the dopamine,
serotonin levels are down.
The coffee is gone.
And you're taking on too much.
And now what I do in those
moments is go, wait a minute,
every time you
persevere, you succeed.
It will happen.
It's not if.
It's when.
And that's my mentality.
And I talk myself off
a ledge all the time.
And I say, just chill, man,
you're going to get this.
It may take a little bit longer.
So I'm back at home,
practicing, going, oh, my god,
what am I doing?
I could have been in the
Jerusalem Symphony Orchestra
with a bow tie,
playing Beethoven
instead of rock and roll.
So I'm practicing,
practicing, practicing.
Finally, a bunch of
guys from Indiana
talk me into moving to Indiana.
We're going to
get a record deal,
make records, and
tour like the Beatles.
I see the business model.
Go there, get a band
house, seven guys in house.
We got an investor
that gave us $30,000--
back then, was a lot of money--
got a truck, PA, lights.
We got a whole business plan.
Three years later, and I'm
living in, by the way--
I think my rent was $62 a month.
I lived on an outdoor porch
converted into a room.
I had a little bed with
an electric blanket,
drum set, stereo, little
teeny closet for clothes.
That was it.
But I was happy, man.
I was going to be
in the Beatles,
or my version of the Beatles.
After three years,
it didn't happen.
I'm going to move back to
New York, create a new plan,
execute.
And then I hear about
this Johnny Cougar guy.
And some girl tells me as
I'm leaving a restaurant
to fly to LA actually to
audition for Lou Rawls,
that this Johnny Cougar
guy just fired his drummer.
Well, I go right
to a pay phone--
no cell phones-- with a
quarter, put it in, call up
the guitar player, because
I'm thinking, wait a minute,
this guy's on this new
TV show called MTV.
And I've seen him,
and he's touring.
He's opening up for Kiss.
And wait a minute,
what am I thinking?
This is what I
always wanted to do,
and it's right here in
Bloomington-- my backyard.
So I'm on the phone
going, I want this.
And the guitar
player says, well,
call back in a couple
weeks, we just got off tour.
I go to LA, didn't get the Lou
Rawls gig, which was probably
very appropriate,
come back, and now I'm
like foaming at the mouth.
I got to do this.
And they tell me
they'll audition.
John has heard about me
being a local big guy
and for my hard work.
Now I earned the right
to have an audition.
That's my point.
I earned it.
So what do I do?
Back to my eight hours a day--
they said, be familiar
with the record.
Be familiar?
Does that mean drink some
beer and listen to the songs,
go, yeah, man, that's cool?
I wrote every single note
out, memorized every song.
I'd walk out of the room and
go, I need a lover, [DRUMMING],,
walk out, and say--
I'd just keep drilling myself.
Play this song, play
those two songs--
I was so ready when I walked in.
When I got to the audition--
I almost didn't even
get to the audition,
because I had this
old, beat-up car.
John's looking at it.
It's leaking oil
on his driveway.
I was not dressed cool
like I am right now.
I was not cool.
I had a drum set the size
of Neil Peart from Rush.
I didn't know John wanted that
Ringo Starr, Charlie Watts, one
rag tom, one floor tom.
And he sees it.
And I go up to him,
hey, Ken Aronoff.
He goes, John Mellencamp,
turns around and walks away.
I'm like, whoa, OK.
So I set up my
big, huge drum set.
And they say, do you
know any of the songs?
I went, oh, yeah I'm
familiar-- "familiar."
I'm ready to dive in the pool.
We play two songs.
I crush everything.
I think I broke cymbals, sticks.
And John goes upstairs and
he yells at Mike, Mike,
get up here.
And I'm packing up.
And I'm nervous, because
I really want this bad.
Mike comes down.
He smiles at me, shakes my
hand, goes, welcome to hell.
I went, yay, ooh.
And I went, what does
he mean by "hell"?
Well, what that meant was John
was a very intense boss, which
I understand.
I give him credit for it.
He grew up with the
name John Mellencamp.
And when he got his record
deal, they changed his name
to Johnny Cougar.
Now he's a proud man
from the Midwest.
And his uncles and his
grandfather and parents
didn't want John Mellencamp
to come home as Johnny Cougar.
I'm just imagining, you know?
What's wrong with your name?
And that's basically
what John said
to the manager, who created
the name for David Bowie, Ziggy
Stardust.
That was kind of an "in"
thing back then where
they would create stage names.
Well, John took it,
because that's all he had.
He didn't have any bargaining.
But he loses his record deal.
And he went back to working
for the telephone company
back in Seymour, Indiana.
That was very humiliating.
Now he's got
another record deal.
This guy did not want
to lose his record deal.
He did not want to go back
to climbing telephone poles.
So me, I was just glad
to be out of the clubs
and maybe get on MTV
and make a record.
But John was way beyond that.
He realized what he could lose.
NICK: So you recorded a ton
of famous songs with John.
But one in particular-- the
famous drum solo that comes
in "Jack and Diane"--
how did that come about?
Because you don't have much
time to work on that, correct?
KENNY ARONOFF: Right.
OK.
First of all, "Jack and Diane"
was John's only number one hit.
And when I mean
number one, back then,
there was only two
formats for radio.
And it was basically
album-oriented rock
where they would play every
cut on an album or top 40,
they played singles.
Album-oriented would
play everything.
And the top 40 stations
would look at the stats.
What were people
most excited about?
What songs do they like?
And they grab those and
put them on the top 40.
And when you became
number one, you
couldn't get us off the radio.
It was on every station, on TV.
We do every TV show imaginable.
By the way, when I got
in the Mellencamp band,
five weeks after being in,
we had to make a record.
Two days later, I'm fired.
I was devastated--
absolutely devastated.
We're at the Chateau Marmont--
this famous hotel with
Belushi died and all these--
I ran into DeNiro
when he was looking
like "Godfather 2"
and Meryl Streep
with hair down to her calves.
And I was Sunset Strip.
I did it.
Mom, I made it.
And then I get fired.
And when John's firing
me, he was basically
saying, because I didn't know
what the purpose of a drummer
is.
And the purpose of a drummer,
which I now know, back then
was really--
my purpose as a drummer is to
get John's songs on the radio
and be number one, because as
an employee of the corporation
John Mellencamp, if he gets
a song to be number one,
he makes gazillions of dollars.
If I was hired by
Microsoft, they
would hire me to make them
gazillions of dollars.
And then I'd get some money,
and I'd raise my family.
But nobody explains
that in rock and roll.
It's just like sex,
drums, rock and roll.
Let's rock.
So I didn't know
that my purpose--
my whole mental approach to
coming up with a drum part
to serve the song to be on
the radio and be number one--
I had no clue of that.
John knew that.
Producer of the
record knew that.
Time was an element.
You've got to get the
drum track done first.
Back then, you had to be able
to play from beginning to end.
There was very little editing.
You had to have your time
down, your feel down,
your sound down--
everything perfect, one take.
There was none of this editing
and pro-tools like you can now.
You can take a crappy drummer
and make him sound OK.
That wasn't happening back then.
And they realized I was green.
So as John was telling
me this, you're
not going to be on the record--
I'm going, nope, nope,
nope, nope, nope, nope,
no, I'm not going home.
Because he was suggesting
I go back to Indiana.
I went, no.
It's almost like
if somebody were
to fire you and you
go, no, I'm not fired.
And they go, no, wait,
I just fired you.
No, you don't mean that.
You don't mean to fire me.
That's what was happening.
And I had to come up with a plan
or some sort of business model
that would benefit
the both of us.
And I did.
And here's how it went.
And I'm scrambling, by the way.
It was like an angel
spoke on my behalf.
Well, [STAMMERING] no, I'm
going to go to the studio
and watch those drummers
play my parts on your songs.
And I'm going to
learn from them.
benefit from that.
Yeah, I'm going to
And I said, am I
still your drummer?
And he went,
perplexed, like, yeah.
I says, well, if I get
better from that and benefit
from that, you're
going to benefit,
because I'm your drummer.
And here's the deal-maker.
I went, you don't
have to pay me.
And I think that did it.
And I'll sleep on the floor.
Well, he didn't pay me,
but I did sleep on a bed.
And it was humiliating.
So I go home four weeks later,
back to eight hours a day
practicing.
I'm trying to learn how
to serve John's songs.
How do you practice
something simple?
It's easy to practice
something technical
or learn something technical.
How do you practice simplicity?
There aren't that many
method books on that.
So I had to create a method.
And I start doing that.
All I could focus on
was the next record.
A year and a half later,
we're making "American Fool."
"Jack and Diane," number one
hit single, was off the record.
We, as a band, didn't know
how to serve the song.
It was a cool folk song.
[SINGING] Little ditty
about Jack and Diane--
that type of thing.
[MIMICKING DRUMS] Now
I had that cool beat.
But it's kind of--
where do you go from there?
It was kind of boring.
You have to develop
it into something.
We didn't know how to do that.
So it's off the record.
One day, a guy walks
in with this metal box.
And I said, what's that?
He says, it's a
Linn 1 drum machine.
What are you going
to do with that?
And he says, well, we're going
to try it on "Jack and Diane"
and program the drum.
I'm going to be replaced
now by a machine?
A human, but a machine--
this is back then.
I grabbed the thing.
I went, I'm going to program it.
So I'm programming my
parts on a drum machine.
And here's your box.
And I go back.
And I'm in the
lounge playing pool
going, man, this really sucks.
I'm now being replaced by a box.
And then all of the sudden,
a couple hours later, Aronoff
get in here.
John says, we need a drum solo.
I'm like, on a ballad?
I'm like, wow.
I'm thinking, what
would Buddy Rich do?
He'd say, the song sucks,
get rid of the song,
give me another song.
Well, I couldn't
do that obviously.
So I have to sit there.
We spent a whole day
getting this big drum song,
because back then, they didn't
put drums in the big room.
They put them in vocal
booths, because you
could control the sound better.
So we spent a whole day trying
to create this new sound.
And then it's time for me to
come up with the big drum solo.
So I was starting
to learn my purpose.
So he said, this is where
we want you to come in.
So I went, boom,
blam, and stopped.
That was my entrance--
like, ta-da--
simple and big.
And I look in the control room.
There's nine guys in there.
And they're like--
I'm like, whew,
still got my job,
because they could replace me.
They did before.
So then I started doing things.
I know I'm going to go--
I was looking at the
thing that everybody--
you can look at something that
everybody sees a certain way.
And then you put a twist on
it by looking at it different.
Typically in drumming,
you go down the tom-toms.
I decided I'd go
up the tom-toms.
And so I hit a deadend.
Next thing you know,
I'm in the control room.
And I got everybody saying,
you should try this,
you should try this, you should
try this, you should try this.
And you're thinking,
wait a minute,
all I know is I've got to
come up with something.
Trying to pay attention
to them, but also
come up with my own ideas--
and I'm like, all I
know is I'm walking back
to the drum set 40 feet.
I remember saying, you got
40 feet to save your career--
30 feet, 20, 15.
What are you going to play?
I don't know.
Oh, my god.
What are you going to do?
Five, one-- I turn around
and there they are.
I felt like a goldfish
in a goldfish tank,
and they're looking down at me.
I'm like-- and the
angel shows up again.
Do this.
I played the rhythm
I had programmed.
And at first, I had
played it on the beat.
"Doosh, doosh,
doo, dun, un, un."
And I went "do, do, do,"
and they didn't like that.
So this time, I moved it over.
The same idea-- moved it
over by an eighth note.
So instead of playing on one,
I go one, two, three, four,
one-- "un, un, un."
The same rhythm,
but displaced, which
gave it a kind of a twist.
I look up-- oh, no, I
didn't even look up.
John hit a cymbal,
which mean obviously he
liked what I just did.
I went "da-ga gsh."
And then I went, "do,
do, do, do, do, do,"
because I had to
go down the drums.
Ran out of drums--
I went back up,
"blah, do, do, doom.
Doosh, ga.
Do, do, do.
Da gong, do, do, do, do, do,
do, do, blah, do, do, doosh."
And then they're
like, do a groove.
Long story short, I came up
with, "doosh, do-ga doosh, goh.
Do do-ga doon, shh.
Doon, do-ga doon, shh."
And on top, they went,
mm-hum, so let it rock.
So let it roll--
became this big anthem thing.
Bingo, number one--
John's a gazillionaire.
And I got credit for being the
drummer on the whole thing.
And it's like,
who's Kenny Aronoff?
Who's this guy?
I was in the same
room that I got
fired in at the Chateau
Marmont where I heard
the song went to number one.
And to be honest with you,
I celebrated for about one
second.
And then I got scared
like, oh, my god, I
have to do this again.
Can I do this again?
How do I do this again?
Whoa-- pressure.
There I was again-- fear.
And yeah, so that was, I'd
say, arriving and executing
my second plan and
reaching a goal.
I now was on a number one
single that's still played today
and launched my career as
a rock and roll drummer.
NICK: And you did it
again a few more times.
KENNY ARONOFF: Not only have
I been on number one singles,
but they were huge, iconic--
like, "I'll Do
Anything for Love,
but I Won't Do That"
by meatloaf, which
that album sold 40 million.
I was on "That Thing You Do"--
the Tom Hanks thing.
You guys may not
remember this song,
but Belinda Carlisle, "Heaven
on Earth" was a huge single.
That was my first number one hit
single outside of Mellencamp.
"Blaze of Glory" by Bon
Jovi was a huge hit--
a very pinnacle moment
for John, because he did
a solo record that
went number one
and sold millions of copies.
I've recorded with
so many people--
Johnny Cash to Tony
Iommi from Sabbath
to Alice Cooper to BB King,
Bonnie Raitt to Mellencamp,
Elton John, Santana, Rod
Stewart to Avril Lavigne,
Celine Dion, Michelle Branch.
It's just all over the map,
which is a difficult thing
to do as a session drummer.
Usually they go,
oh, he's a rock guy.
But there I am, recording with
George Jones, Conway Twitty--
last performance ever.
It's been incredible.
NICK: So let's
transition to the book
where a lot of these
incredible stories are.
How did you find
time to write a book
with all the touring and all the
studios and all the sessions?
Were you able to--
KENNY ARONOFF: Well, I didn't
want to write the book.
Didn't you hear?
I never wanted to write my book.
I knew this was going to be a
pain in the butt, and it was.
I went on tour with
this super-group
called Chickenfoot, which
is Sammy Hagar and Mike
Anthony from Van Halen, and
then the genius guitar player,
Joe Satriani.
And Chad Smith, the drummer
from the Chili Peppers, who's
the original member--
Chad had to go back on
tour with the Chili Peppers
and make his $8
billion a month salary.
Just Joking.
And so Chad said,
Kenny's your guy.
And so Sammy-- and
this is an example
of being successful
also, which I
call communication skills,
teamwork, being able
to get along with people.
Sammy calls you up and goes,
hey, Kenny, it's Sammy.
Listen, there's a lot of
drummers that want this gig,
and there's a lot of drummers
that can play this gig,
but I want somebody I get
along with and have fun with.
Teamwork, communication skills--
I get hired more, probably,
because people want me
in the room next to them,
because I motivate the room.
I'm a good guy to have around.
Doesn't matter if I've been on
over 300 million records sold--
I still know that I am there.
I listen.
I learn.
I lead, because I'm a drummer.
But I ain't the boss.
If I want to be the boss,
then I become the boss.
Till I'm the boss, yes,
sir, what would you like?
The 15-year-old kid that hires
me to play on the record--
how would you like
me to do that?
I have to still consider
that I'm an employee.
So yeah, I said to
Sammy, well, why don't we
get together and hang out?
And then we'll
play a little bit.
I'll fly myself up there
in northern California.
And that's what we did.
And I got the gig.
So the writer that's
writing about Joe Satriani--
a book he was
writing-- said, god,
I want to do a book on you.
And I went, nah.
He said, no, no, really,
it will be great.
And I says, well, I
don't want to just talk
about recording and touring.
I want to talk
about other things.
Whatever you want
to talk about--
he made it sound like
all I do is dictate
into the phone every so
many weeks or every month,
and then he transcribes it.
And next thing you know,
we got a great book.
Boy, was I naive.
My gut was telling me, this
is not going to work out easy.
What happened after
about two years--
no disrespect to the writer--
it didn't sound like me.
So now I've got to take over.
And I have a couple
of friends out there
in the audience right now,
they know what it's like for me
to take over.
I have a vision that--
I realize only I
understand my vision.
And so I had to go and
edit every single page.
Once again, no disrespect to
the editor, who was brilliant,
and the writer that
was co-writing with me.
But it didn't sound like me.
I couldn't stomach
letting one page go by.
So I'd spend 16 hours a
day on my days off on tour,
pulling my hair out.
Well, it was already out.
Pulling something,
pacing, and just
rewriting one chapter for
weeks till it sounded like me.
And by the way, they
cut 300 pages out.
There's some juicy stuff-- a
thing with me and Cameron Diaz.
And me and Dave
Grohl and all this
stuff that you would
love to know about,
but they had to cut it
out, because there wasn't
enough room to put it in there.
Next book.
Or I'll see you after this.
The thing is, is that it
was an amazing experience.
It was like making a movie.
They leave more on the floor
than they put in the movie.
And to shape a
book, what I learned
is the way you shape
a book and there's
certain techniques and
supposed to be a certain length
and at this point, you've got
to put a little bit of humor in.
At this point, you put a
little bit of a story here.
And I'm very proud of the
way the book came out.
I'm very, very proud.
But it was really,
really difficult.
And the trip is, it's not
like my career is over.
I wrote it while I'm still
relevant and happening.
And the best thing
about it is what
I learned about my own
life is teaching me.
I literally said, so well--
people ask me, how
did you do this?
How did you play on so many
records, so diverse, a touring
career, 10 years with Joe
Cocker, touring, making
records--
17 years with Mellencamp,
touring, making records--
the Smashing Pumpkins, 24
years with John Fogerty,
the iconic songwriter
of America,
the Creedence Clearwater--
records and touring and Melissa
Etheridge for 10 years, Michelle
Branch, the Jefferson Airplane,
a Bob Seger--
blah, blah, blah, touring,
and then stylistically
all over the map.
How did you do--
I sort of asked myself
the same question.
Wait a minute, if I have to
explain this to somebody,
how did I do this?
So I came up with this.
I believe there are
seven ways a person can
be successful in their
life and their career--
the same seven ways that led
me to this extraordinary career
in one of the most
difficult businesses
in the world for four decades--
the music business.
It's such a broken
business, man,
for the drummer, the musician.
It's so difficult. It
doesn't work like it used to.
Like, I'm on three records
that sold 40 million copies.
That's a lot of money
coming into the corporation
that then they
reinvest in new bands,
like the John Mellencamp band.
You have millions of dollars
to get songs on the radio,
to promote it, to put
the band on the tour,
to invest and invest and invest.
And it worked.
That business model worked,
only because the companies were
making money from selling CDs.
That doesn't happen anymore.
So the investment
money is not there.
So that business model
kind of fell apart.
So my point is, I came up
with several ways I truly
believe that this works.
And when I talk about
seven ways or fundamentals,
there is no magic pill.
There is no genius
thing that somebody
is going to come up with and
say, whew, if you do this,
this will change your life.
Nobody's ever said this before.
It's all been said.
But fundamentals at
anything are what
makes us become successful
and stay successful.
Why do we look at
the 10 Commandments?
To remind us how to live our
life with certain values.
We have to keep looking
at them, because we
get sidetracked sometimes.
I know I have on
my third marriage.
So the thing is--
are they going to edit that out?
No.
But my point is that
fundamentals are fundamentals.
I don't care if it's sports,
music, living your life--
anything.
There are fundamentals
that work.
And sometimes we
have to be reminded.
And when I speak--
I have a speaking business--
I remind people maybe
of these fundamentals.
And my version is my version.
But it gets down to, it's always
going to be self-discipline.
It's always going
to be hard work.
It's always going to be
able to create a plan,
execute it to reach your goal.
It's always going to
be communication skills
and teamwork skills.
It's always going to be, well,
I talk about a healthy life
is a wealthy life.
No mental, physical,
and emotional health--
you can't go to work.
You can't get out of bed.
And I have eight steps
to being healthy.
This is important.
These are fundamentals
that we have
to be reminded of all the time.
And my last one is staying
relevant and staying focused
to stay relevant to adapt.
For example, in my business,
the vinyl record went out.
CD came, turned into Frisbees.
Downloading, streaming--
all the sudden,
people couldn't afford to fly me
from Indiana all over the world
to make a record.
I had dreams in New
York, Nashville, LA,
Japan, and Germany.
And all of a sudden,
the budgets went.
What did I do?
Got an apartment in LA,
eventually moved to LA,
eventually got a studio.
People couldn't afford to pay
2 and 1/2 1,000, $3,000 a day
to be in a studio.
So I have a studio.
Studio's free.
I'm not free, but
the studio is free.
And I created a
business model that
has kept me relevant
in the music business
where people hire me to record--
I just did this cool band,
Supersonic Blues Machine.
I went to play with Billy
Gibbons, Steve Lukather, Robben
Ford, Warren Haynes--
on and on.
Great guitar players-- we
feature guitar players,
all done in my studio.
I just did a song with
Sammy Hagar and DMC,
on and on and on.
I've made it
affordable, and I've
had to adjust to the way
my business has changed.
We're basically the
horse and buggy business,
and the car showed
up 15 years ago.
But I'm still riding the buggy.
NICK: So this part,
we're going to open up
to audience questions.
We have two mics.
While people are lining up,
I'll do a few rapid fire.
What's the most memorable
show you ever played?
KENNY ARONOFF: The inauguration
maybe or the Kennedy Center
honors--
Obama's inauguration or
the Kennedy Center honors.
NICK: What's your
favorite venue to play at?
KENNY ARONOFF:
Madison Square Garden.
NICK: And what's your favorite
city you've visited on tour?
KENNY ARONOFF: Oh, that's tough.
Oh, I've been in 62 countries.
Can I narrow it down?
Places like New York, LA--
they're just the
center of everything.
So I love playing
in these cities.
NICK: OK.
We have-- we'll start over here.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Hi.
KENNY ARONOFF: How
you doing, man?
AUDIENCE: So entertaining.
Thank you so much
for being here.
KENNY ARONOFF: Oh,
you're welcome.
Thank you for having me.
AUDIENCE: Of course.
I want to thank
whoever organized this.
This is awesome.
I'm a drummer.
And I just--
I don't know.
This is a treat.
Thank you.
I had two questions.
I can ask one if you want.
They're mostly specifically
about playing and writing
music.
When you do drum parts,
do you like usually
working with the
backing track or do
you prefer working with
the live musicians?
Like, say, do you prefer
laying down your drum parts
with the guitar and
the bass player?
Or do you prefer just listening
to the tracks and just--
KENNY ARONOFF:
That's a great ques--
AUDIENCE: Things like to
the grid with a click now--
KENNY ARONOFF: Well,
that's a great question.
And I'll tell you how I do it.
Obviously, I prefer
playing in the studio
with all the players
at the same time,
because there's
that interaction.
And the better the
players, the better it is,
because boy, they'll push
you and you push them.
But nowadays, with
that business model
that I was telling you
about, a lot of times, people
send me demos.
Sammy sent me an electric
guitar and his voice--
bad ass.
It was so bad-- so inspiring.
But there was an open palette.
So can you imagine,
oh, my god, I
don't want to do the wrong
thing, what is your vision,
Sammy?
That's the first thing I asked.
And he goes, well, kind of
make it like Led Zeppelin.
And I went, OK.
So I ask a few more questions.
Since it was a duet
with DMC, I says,
who's singing the verses,
who's singing the chorus?
And so when I know DMC's
going to do the verses,
then I'm going to play
with a little bit of space
to allow him to do his thing.
Bottom line is, I get a click.
I want the guitar part and the
vocal part that Sammy recorded.
And I want the click track
that he recorded, too,
because we got to have a
click track, because then I'm
going to play to the click
track and they're going
to overdub everything to me.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
KENNY ARONOFF: OK.
So I write everything out.
I'm very meticulous so
that when I go in there,
I'm like, bam, bam,
bam, bam, bam, bam.
It's live.
I'm excited.
I'm pumped.
It's like, I've done
all the prep work.
OK, let's go to a
different scenario.
Sometimes people will send me
demos with all kinds of parts--
guitar, bass, keyboards.
First thing I ask
them is like, are you
keeping any of these parts?
And if they say no, which
is usually what they do,
that's good, because
then I put the click up,
because I want to make sure
I'm tight with the click track,
because they're
going to overdub.
Then I ask them, well, are
these parts the parts that--
even though they're not
the parts you're going to--
the actual recording of
those parts, but those
are the basic parts that
you're going to overdub to me.
So I want to make sure that
my parts will fit with theirs.
And when they say yes,
then that tells me a lot.
Most of the demos I'll get will
already have a drum program.
And this is the part
you'll like here.
So what I do is I write out
everything in the program,
because when they say,
just do your own thing--
I learn the hard way.
When they say, "do
your own thing,"
they've been listening to
those drum parts for so long
that they don't
really mean that.
They mean, do your
own thing to a point.
So what I do is I
write everything out.
Everything-- cymbal, tom-toms.
And I'll give them one take
precisely what they programmed,
but with my feel.
The next take I
give them is now I
start putting in my own fills.
I might, instead of the
open high hat in the chorus,
go to the crash cymbal.
Or maybe in the B section, I
play fours like a Motown beat,
because I feel like
it drives it more.
The third take, I
go even further.
That way, you see how I'm
taking care of everything.
I hope that helped.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Can I ask one more thing?
KENNY ARONOFF: Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, one, can I?
It's related to that.
How do you take
this-- sometimes you
might get not very
clear guidance
on what they want you to do.
Do you have any
tips for language
when they tell you, oh, I
want it to be more open,
or I want it to be more intense?
How do you take that?
KENNY ARONOFF: This is
that people skill thing.
I did a record with Billy Corgan
from the Smashing Pumpkins
and Tony Iommi
from Black Sabbath.
Billy walks in.
He goes right down to business.
Says, Tony, play me a lick
you've been working on,
because Tony comes up
with the greatest licks.
[MIMICKING GUITAR] Billy
plays it on guitar or bass.
And I went, man, that's bad ass.
He said, give me another.
[MIMICKING GUITAR] I'm like,
ooh, that's so awesome.
Billy looks at me and goes--
I went, does that mean you
want me to go out there?
Yeah.
I go out there.
I'm on the drums.
OK.
No vocals-- I start writing down
dark section, purple section.
Then I hear Billy said,
no, be more fluent.
OK, fluent-- OK, fluent--
I'm sitting there going,
does he mean by "fluent"?
So I have to come
up with something.
And what I always do when they
say something like, be this--
Brian Wilson from the Beach
Boys once said something to me.
I was overdubbing.
I went, oh, my god,
what does he mean?
What do I do, because I don't
understand what he's saying?
And this is the great Brian
Wilson from the Beach Boys.
Here's what I do in a
situation like that.
Do something.
Just do anything.
Do the best that you can do.
And wait for them to tell
you, no, make it more like--
and now you've got the
thing going back and forth.
If you just go,
what do you mean--
that's where you blow it.
If you ask them to
explain it again--
unless you're with somebody
you're real close to
and you got that chemistry.
But there was no way I was going
to do that with those guys.
I just, oh, OK.
And a lot of times, yeah,
that's exactly what I meant.
I'm like, whew.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
KENNY ARONOFF: Awesome.
NICK: Go over.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Thanks, again, so much
for being here today.
KENNY ARONOFF: Could you
just speak a little closer
to the mic?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, of course.
So it was interesting
listening to you
talk about all the tracks
that you've been a part of,
all the artists that
you've worked with.
And in a lot of
these cases, I think
that the recognition
of the songs
goes towards the front man or
the front woman of the band.
I'm curious, as a drummer, if
that's a frustration for you,
or if it's almost considered
a blessing that you're sort
of not the recognizable one.
KENNY ARONOFF: I've
always understood my role,
so to speak, as a drummer.
But at the same time, I'm
not the mellowest guy.
I have a way of being the
second spotlight on stage,
and not on purpose.
It's just my nature.
But the bottom line
is, I'm cool with--
I've never had a problem.
Usually, the guy up front or the
girl up front writes the songs.
They hire me.
It's about them.
I understand that.
And maybe it's just
the way I'm wired.
But I'm cool with my position.
The only time I
get uncomfortable
is when somebody doesn't
treat me with respect
when I'm trying my hardest to
make them look like rock stars.
I'm trying to make the
team win the Super Bowl.
And then someone's
throwing spears at me.
That's like, come on.
So I'm OK with it.
The cool thing is now that
I've been doing speaking,
I'm up front, kind
of like right now.
And I still get to perform.
And I love it.
But basically, I
understand my role.
And I really feel
honorable doing what I do.
And it's perfectly cool.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thank you.
KENNY ARONOFF: Yeah.
Did you want me to play
in your band or something?
Because dude, I've got a studio.
AUDIENCE: It's
really interesting
hearing you speak about a lot
of these history of the music
industry and the general
trend and direction.
I've been reflecting
on these, because I've
just recently seen a documentary
on HBO, "The Defiant Ones."
And I guess I was curious
about if you'd seen it,
if you had thoughts on
it, and just in general,
where you think the general
direction of the industry
is going.
KENNY ARONOFF: I
haven't seen that one.
Is that the one with--
AUDIENCE: It's
with Jimmy Iovine.
KENNY ARONOFF:
Yeah, Jimmy Iovine.
And I've known Jimmy
for a long time
when he was just a producer.
And he is an example
of somebody--
I think somebody
mentioned that he
talks about how he just pounded
and pounded and pounded.
AUDIENCE: Your
stories are similar.
KENNY ARONOFF: Yeah.
So he did it in his
way in the business,
and I did it my way
in the business.
Yeah, we both are
bald and beautiful.
No, joking.
It just sounds good-- bald,
beautiful, and bad ass.
Bald, beautiful, bad ass--
anyway, like I said,
the music business
has drastically changed.
The thing that I am
most frustrated with
and disappointed
with is that I feel
that given that the
budgets are where they are,
that mediocrity has
been accepted too much.
I think mediocrity is an
epidemic across the board--
that people are
settling for stuff
that doesn't have
the value that I
think that music, in my
business, has had in the past.
And it's the whole
system perpetuates that,
because you don't have money.
When I was with Mellencamp,
we could do a whole album
and throw it away and
start again, painfully,
because we had the money
and the budget to do that.
John wasn't loaded, and
we lived in Indiana.
But we would throw away stuff
and come up with great stuff.
Four years-- I thought it was
going to be a year and a half.
Great stuff takes time.
I was talking to
a movie producer,
because Kodak Film is going
to do a documentary on me.
And I was talking to
another film producer.
And he's talking about
seven years making--
I think he was involved with
the Janis Joplin documentary.
And six years on this--
things take time.
And time is attached to
money a lot of times.
That's the problem.
So there's a lot of stuff that
is being praised as a genius,
and it's not.
I'm sorry.
It just is not.
And when I say
"mediocrity," the thing
is, if people are saying they
love that, then they love that.
And then if people
are buying that,
then it's considered successful.
But that doesn't mean
it's genius or great.
I guess that's what I'm saying.
And that's OK, man, because
everything's in trends.
When you have stuff like
that that will perpetuate,
other people go, no.
People somehow find a way
of writing and creating
great stuff, whatever
business they're in.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KENNY ARONOFF: You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: I'll try
to make it quick.
Thanks for the talk.
It was very interesting
and inspiring.
I guess my question is--
the two things-- rock and
roll and working hard--
by intuition, they don't
go along that well, right?
And as a kid, it
seems like you talked
about looking at Ringo Starr.
And I think when Lennon was
asked about Ringo Starr,
whether he's the best
drummer in the world,
he said something like,
he's not even the best
drummer in the Beatles.
So my question is,
as a young kid,
how could you see through
something that looks easy?
How could you see through it and
realize it demands hard work?
And how can we
teach our kids today
that this is the way to go and
it's not as easy as it seems,
like going to Joshua Tree
and just produce a number one
record?
KENNY ARONOFF: Well,
the reason why--
yeah.
When you're a little kid,
I'm looking at the Beatles
like, I want to do that.
I was naive.
I thought you get up there.
But when I started to try
to do that, I realized,
wow, this is hard.
This isn't good.
Then you start practicing.
And you're seeing it
doesn't come quickly.
I didn't mention the fifth
thing in my seven keys
to be successful,
which is called RPS--
Repetition of anything is
the Preparation for Success.
Jason Day, this amazing golfer,
won seven PGA tournaments
in 10 months last year.
Six hours a day, seven
days a week, he practiced.
And that's what
made him successful.
And to stay successful, six
hours a day, seven days a week.
You have to be reminded, man.
I can't just become
Ringo Starr by saying
I want to be Ringo Starr.
I have to practice.
So I learned very quickly,
woo, this is not easy.
And the thing is, I was
watching Buddy Rich back then.
Rock had just come in.
So it was like Buddy Rich,
Elvin Jones, Gene Krupa,
Louie Bellson--
all these amazing jazz drummers
that had really practiced,
had all this technique.
I didn't know where
to begin with that,
because they were way above me.
The other thing that took me
a while-- because back then,
people would go like,
ah, Ringo Starr--
look at Buddy Rich.
And Ringo's just doing, "I
want to hold your hand."
But then later on, I realized,
wow, style, personality, vibe,
influence to the
corporation, the team--
that's what he was brilliant at.
Mick Jagger-- I recorded
with the Stones.
And Mick said, I was
playing on a beaded gourd
with a brush [HUMMING] at
the beginning of a song.
Charlie Watts is
playing the high hat.
Mick comes up to me and
says, be careful not
to get in the way of
Charlie Watts' high hat,
the vibe and the--
it would be as if you did
stroke across a canvas like,
oh, I can do--
wow, that's really good.
Something about it is magical.
Charlie Watts is that guy.
Mick said, no Charlie
Watts, no Stones.
I went, that guy
knows who he has.
He gets it.
Mick gets it.
He understands the
genius of Charlie Watts,
even though he's simple.
He is brilliant.
Same with Ringo--
on paper people
go, oh, man, I don't get it.
It's not technical.
It's not [DRUMMING SOUND],,
you know, all that.
But they are serving the
song and the team geniusly,
and affect everybody.
Those two things I just told you
about is what made me realize,
wow, you can't sit on
a couch and drink beer,
smoke pot, and
expect to be great.
And if you do get
lucky, because you just
happen to be the coolest
band in the world
and somebody wrote a genius
thing, to do it again,
you're going to have
to eventually be
disciplined and have a formula.
It's like anything else.
To repeat and repeat
and repeat and repeat,
you've got to
understand what it takes
to do that in any business.
NICK: Perfect.
Thanks, everybody.
That's all the time we have.
We have Kenny's book
for sale in the back.
He'll be signing them.
So come on back.
And Kenny, thanks for
being here with us today.
KENNY ARONOFF: Awesome.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]